What is the place of ecology in the programs of presidential candidates?
There was a call from 1,400 scientists calling on candidates to address issues
of environmental biodiversity and climate and global protection.
Valérie Pécresse the candidate of the right in the presidential election.
It actually proposes the development of the car and electric public transport
and then it is all about the development of nuclear power because as you know
nuclear power is the most decarbonized energy even if there is always a question
about the treatment of nuclear waste and always about nuclear power.
Well,
you also have candidates who come from the left yannick jadot jean luc mélenchon
who have rather hard positions but overall who do not say that we must stop
nuclear power right away now because they are aware that if two of us stop
nuclear power tomorrow we have no capacity to supply ourselves with energy
and to supply the whole country to France.
And I wanted to ask you the question,
do you think we talk enough about ecology in this presidential campaign.